lavrov mais ces sanctions sont elles
suffisantes et qu'elles vont être leurs
impacts romain michelot et léo magouët
en seulement quelques heures les
sanctions qui visent la russie
s'accumulent et viennent du monde entier
d'abord contre vladimir poutine l'union
européenne et le royaume uni ont gelé
tous les avoirs du responsable du
kremlin estimé à plusieurs milliards
d'euros mais les sanctions les plus
sévères devraient davantage affecté
l'économie russe d'abord son secteur
commercial les pays de l'ue eux n'ont
plus le droit d'exporter dans
l'aéronautique et la technologie de
pointe ensuite son secteur financier les
banques américaines doivent désormais
rompre leurs relations avec sberbank
plus grands créanciers de russie d'ici
30 jours alors faut-il aller plus loin
oui selon ce spécialiste les sanctions
occidentales qui ont été décidés
n'auront pas un impact extrêmement
important sur l'économie russe en tout
cas beaucoup moins que ce qui avait été
anticipé par les occidentaux tout
simplement parce que la russie avait
déjà prévu depuis plusieurs années et on
peut noter déjà depuis 2014 c'est la
période où on a une annexion de la
crimée que la russie avait décidé un peu
de mettre en place un système afin
d'être moins réceptive moins impactés
par d'éventuelles sanctions ces
sanctions vladimir poutine s'y était
préparé en quatre ans les réserves d'or
et de devises du pays ont
considérablement augmenté de 448
milliards de dollars de réserves en 2018
la russie en dispose de plus de 630
milliards aujourd'hui autre atout avec
l'ukraine les deux pays représente un
quart de la production mondiale de blé
la guerre fait déjà craindre des risques
de pénurie face à la russie l'europe
dispose encore d'un levier conséquent
prénommé swift un système de messagerie
qui facilite les transactions
financières dans le monde entier en
exclure les banques russes auraient un
effet immédiat sur l'activité du pays
une mesure qui divise en europe mais que
l'ukraine continue de demander
les pays de l'ue soutiennent déjà
presque totalement la décision de couper
la russie de swift
j'espère que l'allemagne et la hongrie
auront le courage de soutenir cette
décision
nous avons le courage de défendre notre
patrie de défendre l'europe et
kiev appelle également à un embargo sur
le pétrole russe dont l'europe au même
titre que le gaz est très dépendante